Who wrote Gatubela by Karol G As
well as the Gatúbela who is sitting here I
went to Ibiza to write part of my
album there we make a lot of music and it
turns out that I was recording a
song at that moment someone sent me
some bits and we gave them Play and I remember
that at that moment I was alone with Jake
and I said like Oh my God this Beat
sounds old school that bit sounds like
something from many years ago They listened to
reggaeton And we started to throw
ideas of what we would write And I always
have As I always bring to the table
what I like, I don't know how to give
women different personalities in my
songs like El maquinón bichota in
each of them and well, this was the
moment of the catwoman